it's beautiful it's you know what I'm
born and raised in the City of Angels
this is late October and the City of
Angels writ large look at this I mean
this is just a beautiful night in Los
Angeles we're on we're at the Chinese
Theatre it's el capitan is right there
can't tell you how many Disney movies I
saw there with my kids so what does this
mean to you it means so much to the fans
and there's so much buzz about the film
people are so excited about it I know
this is supposed to be Michael Nouri
sort of last confrontation but now
you're seeing that people want more
could there be more I can't explain why
this genre touches people and makes them
love it
there are rabid fans that have loved
Michael Myers and Laurie Strode and the
relationship between the two of them for
a very long time and I don't understand
it
I really don't but I'm grateful to them
because without them I really wouldn't
have a career so I can't really explain
it except clearly it has sort of touched
a chord again and that's great and you
know Never Say Never Never Say Never I
love that so much
ICI has ranked you the number one scream
queen of the last 40 years what advice
do you have for the future scream queen
so basically want to be you do I get a
little pin or something I mean I wish do
we have a pan or a trophy nothing right
chocolate bar I'm sorry it's an a they
gave me an A for being a plus a list or
forty years later
Wow thank you so much do you have advice
for people who love i'm thank you yes my
dinner um do you have advice for people
that want to be you
oh you're funny um I don't even know
what that means what does that mean like
people who love this genre that say who
you know like Oh Jimmy Lee Curtis she's
the best ever scrape queen I want to be
her you know what I just honestly every
job I've ever gotten I didn't expect to
get I got and then I did the best I
could
it's really that simple suit up show up
be early stay late say please and thank
you bring cookies sorry everybody
and you know last thing rumor has it
that Jake Gyllenhaal played a major role
in getting you to do this film can you
tell us that your connective tissue so
Jake and I have known each other for a
very long time Maggie and Jake are the
children of friends of mine and I knew
them from when they were little and Jake
called me Jake called me in Idaho when I
was on vacation and he said that he had
worked with David Gordon Green on
stronger and that he had a great
relationship and very creative
experience and he said he wants to talk
to you about a movie and would you be
interested in talking to him and I said
sure and here I stand at the premiere
you know we didn't have a premiere for
Halloween you did it oh it was nothing
it just sort of came out there was
nothing I think we had a party at my
house or something I know that a lot of
Laurie strength comes from her
intelligence and her sort of badassery
but this is a very physical movie and
maybe the most physical she's ever been
did you have any injuries onset how was
that the physical aspect of this role it
was hard the whole thing was very hard
yeah I mean it's the nature of the beast
I ended up with a cracked rib at the end
of it and you know bruised and cut but
it is the nature of the beast if you
don't get hurt you're not doing it right
because because in order to do it you
have to get hurt now obviously they try
to protect you from big injuries but
Judy Greer talked to Judy Greer about
the last sequence in the movie and asked
her how she
feeling because she was on these stairs
and she had to go up and down them on
her hip I'm probably was probably the
color of your microphone her entire body
okay and last thing don't look behind
you but we're on this up we're on a sub
bra kind of thing
[Music]